احذر من الأرنب في يوم من الأيام كان
يعيش أرنبًا لا بيتر رابيت نحن
نتحدث عن أرنب مهدد
يعيش في مدينة بيري أيوا الصغيرة ،
أرنب أسود ، أرنب سيئ ، أرنب تم القبض عليه وهو
يندفع ، هذا شخص
ربما يتوقع  نوع محبوب من
الأرانب صادفته رامونا روستين أيضًا ، لقد
قفزت لأعلى وعضتني وأنا
مثل يا إلهي ، لقد تعرضت للتو للعض من قبل
أرنب ، يوضح تقرير شرطة بيري أنه
أيضًا طفل يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا والذي كان عليه بعد ذلك
الحصول على طلقات داء الكلب  طاردت
مقيمًا آخر من سيارتها إلى بابها ولا
عجب أنه تمت مقارنتها بدراكولا
من الأرانب بانيكيولا ، أرنب مصاص دماء
مع أرانب أنياب لطالما كان
يسيء الفم في الأفلام التي تم تصويرها على أنها أرانب متحولة
قادرة على قطع رأس فارس في مونتي
بايثون والقدس  جريل
[موسيقى]
ولكن سادت رؤوس أكثر برودة عندما
استدرجت شرطة بيري الأرنب السيئ إلى قفص
وأخذته إلى
محطة معالجة المياه بالمدينة حيث تم إطلاق سراحه
ولم يُشاهد خبأ ولا شعر الأرنب
منذ أي مخلوقات شيطانية
ما
مجهول سينما الإرهاب سي إن إن  نيويورك
وهذا كل شيء يا رفاق